get attention like get as much attention
as you can and and focus on it people
say to me a lot to college people
you know college age they they say brad
what would you do if you could start
over at 20.
i said i would master marketing
yeah
when you can drive leads and get
attention which is marketing to me drive
leads and interest that's the tension
if you master marketing you're
guaranteed to make seven figures plus
like people big companies will pay you
seven figures to drive leads their way
but when you have the ability to grab
attention get leads get interest
digitally especially
you've got that ability that skill
you can drive it towards selling
freaking coffee mugs with a with a word
on it and end up becoming the number one
coffee mug
dealer in the world
get attention
welcome to episode 108 of the michaela
peterson podcast today's guest always
says if it's not a win-win it's not a
deal
but having him here is a win for me and
for you guys
i'm pleased to welcome my guest brad lee
he is a serious entrepreneur he founded
lightspeed vt which is a company known
for its interactive web-based courses
and training that i think i might try
out they're pretty cool
he shared his perspectives on the skills
needed that lead to an entrepreneur's
success he explained the significance of
social media and improving sales skills
he's quite a salesman when to fire
someone when to hire someone how to like
yourself how to balance family and
careers there's a lot in here he's the
host of dropping bombs podcast that has
super fun interviews if you enjoyed this
please remember to subscribe
[Music]
bradley welcome to my podcast
thanks for having me i'm excited
i'm excited too i'm going to ask you a
whole bunch of questions about starting
a business and running in business and
being an
entrepreneur okay
first question though can or first ask i
guess could you please give a brief
background about who you are and what
you do
sure
i am a
entrepreneur kind of serial entrepreneur
i've got several businesses the one i'm
most known for is lightspeed vt which is
a web-based
software i started about 20 years ago
when the internet began
and now it's kind of serving as the
software for a lot of different training
programs whether it be you know gurus
and and colleges and you know franchises
etc and i also started a podcast called
drop bombs that got a little popularity
but other than that you know i'm just a
serial entrepreneur looking for ways to
you know generate revenue opportunity
and uh i i kind of i kind of like uh
i would say
i don't want to say influencer because i
hate that word
uh but but i'm starting to get a little
following on social media
that's it
author i'm about i've really i've
finished my book finally so now i'm an
author too oh wow congratulations what's
the book called it's called the hard way
lessons i've learned the hard way so you
don't have to
oh nice okay well maybe i'll ask you a
little bit about that too i'm definitely
gonna ask you a little bit about that
too i've been wondering what the hell is
michaela gonna ask me
i'm just gonna pick your brain about
being an entrepreneur and an influencer
apparently you can use the term content
creator that makes people feel better
yeah it's a bit different i think
yeah
i wrote that down i'm gonna start using
the sounds better again your intellect
is impressive continue
it's the same thing it's just a sneakier
way of putting it
okay
you how do you feel about the education
system and how that teaches
entrepreneurship
well i think it's broken and i don't
think it teaches entrepreneurship at all
i think it's antiquated i think it was
created a hundred years ago and it
hasn't changed much
now there are thought leaders that that
buck the system a little bit but
in
you know as a general statement i think
it's broken and antiquated
it doesn't teach anything that that you
actually use you know
like
pre-algebra calculus you know for
example like
do they teach you that so you do well at
calculus season
they're not teaching the right topics to
build a business you know how to build
relationships how to nurture
relationships you know
cells you know if i did if i weren't
able to sell and persuade
i wouldn't be where i'm at today and i
don't know if there's any sales courses
in in
even in high school but definitely i
don't even think there there's many in
higher education you tell me
or as you call it university
university yes us canadians i i don't
know i think there are marketing i think
they're marketing courses you can take
so that might teach sales but is there a
way to actually teach sales or is that
something that's just kind of innate
oh no you can teach sales i think we're
all i think we're all in sales most
people want to deny it especially ones
that hate sales but we're all in sales
we're in sales from the day we come out
of the womb i mean we're coming out
we've got to sell somebody on some food
we got to sell somebody to quit slapping
us
but uh it can be learned it can be
learned
okay so do you have any
yeah do you have tricks for that then
like what kind of i mean you're
obviously good at sales i've watched
your podcast i've i know your products
which we'll get into but uh do you have
tips for how to improve your sales
skills
well i mean i
believe it or not
when i teach people how to sell i teach
them not to sell because i think
nowadays
sales is more about building
relationships than it is you know trying
to convince you to do something
if i approach the relationship as i want
to you know build a relationship with
michaela let me see how i can help her
and i start to ask questions and i'm
listening intently you know that's just
a conversation but
knowing the right questions to ask
depending on what i'm selling or or the
product or service that i represent
would would then tell me what questions
to ask you so you could give me the
answers that i need to build value in
this product or service based on you so
it's really not that difficult once
someone understands that it's kind of
like you know mixed martial arts
fighting you know you you get into the
ring with a black belt you're going to
get your ass kicked
but
if you study and learn the moves and
practice the moves and know that there
are
moves and techniques
pretty soon you're in there with the
best of them
so learn skill for sure okay that makes
sense so part of it is building trust in
a relationship right
100 percent
okay that makes sense
um so you talked about college education
a bit do you think college education is
a good way to judge who you're hiring
how do you hire people what do you look
for
[Applause]
i personally you know have a lot of
people that work for me that have
degrees i dropped out of high school
believe it or not um well very
believable isn't it but in the 11th
grade i dropped out of high school
thought i was going to be a movie star
ran off to la
uh never went back
but i hire a lot of people with degrees
and they just happen to have degrees i
don't look for degrees unless i'm hiring
somebody like a lawyer
so
in my opinion
i believe college or university is
something everyone should aspire to do
pick up the education while you're there
but it's more to build relationships
like i'd go to college to meet my
potential wife and my potential business
partners and my lifelong friends i
wouldn't be going to get the education
nowadays with the internet the way it is
you can learn from
people that have actually done it now
again
there's rare occasions like like jordan
b peterson but
in the most part a lot of these
professors that are teaching are just
are just teaching what they've learned
out of a book or a textbook which was
written by
and it just continues to go so nowadays
i would go
to college 100 to build relationships
build your network
okay that makes sense
but you can learn whatever you want
online like anything they even have
online university now some of the
courses are free from some of the really
impressive universities or colleges in
the states
100
harvard harvard is coming out with the
mba fully online for for not much money
wow that's cool okay it's good to know
okay how have you managed to balance
your career and your family life
you know i don't think there's
such thing as balance i just pay
attention to the priorities meaning you
know squeaky wheel gets the grease
i've went
you know three months where my
business was the most important thing i
had to deal with
family life was was fine uh i don't
think your kids want to spend as much
time with you as you think they do or
would like to think that they do
you know and i think if you give quality
time while you're there
uh everything's gonna work out
personally
i see these guys you know they're so
worried about their family that they're
broke
you know oh i i have to spend quality
time with my kids it's gonna mean
something when they grow up i i don't
think so my dad my dad
didn't spend a lot of time with me our
relationship was fine um but when i got
a little older he couldn't help me he
was broke
so so
look at the people that are spending all
this time with their kids raising
wonderful kids but they're broke
why can't you
kind of
allow the priorities to to
because if my kids had something where i
had to go home and pay attention to them
for three months six months straight i'm
gonna do that other than that it's just
priorities i mean how do you do it
you got a little one running around
well i've outsourced some of it so my
nanny her name's uli
i found somebody who i really trust
so she's like family
so it kind of feels like i have external
family watching scarlet and i can judge
that based on how scarlett's acting with
me like is she sad does she miss me or
is she just having a ball all the time
and so i've set it up so she's enjoying
her life all the time
she's happy when i'm around i'm happy
when i'm around but
i think you're right about kids not
needing you as much as you think they do
i mean it depends on what age they are
right obviously if they're babies
and obviously if you notice something a
little peculiar you might stop working a
little bit more than normal and go pay
attention a little bit more than normal
so that's kind of just how i deal with
it you know i hope i hope i'm doing okay
i have six kids so so um you have six
kids sounds like you're doing fine
yeah and all of them are turning out
okay you know
so so i i think i accidentally got
through it i'm no i'm no parental expert
i can tell you that
okay
okay how do you feel about social media
and its necessity for running a business
nowadays
oh it's critical you know i find these
people that are hitting me up all the
time what's the secret to success what
do i do what do i do and i go look at
their social media and they're on
private
well
that's basically the that's basically
the equivalence of
putting up a
closed sign on your store
like you know people don't follow
companies they follow people
you know i i don't even know like
like i don't even know what a lot of
people's company
is is but i know who they are people
follow you know richard branson they
don't follow virgin so
social media is your
reputation it's your business card it's
your exposure and i think it's critical
and i think anyone that doesn't
understand that is probably playing too
small
yeah
or being a bit arrogant about social
media a lot of people are like you know
like the word influencer right you're
like well i don't want to be an
influencer i have more important things
to do it's like well that's your
marketing right there so
yeah not only that you want to know
something that's mind-blowing a lot of
times
people don't like themselves
and they're not even aware of it so
social media is a mirror it's a
reflection or at least it should be of
who you are and what you stand for and
what your opinion is and a lot of times
uh people
run away from that because they don't
know who they are and they don't know
what their opinion is they're they're
basically just
you know zombies and followers and
they're just they just have no opinion
and when you take that away you start to
look underneath what why well i think
it's because ultimately deep down they
don't really like themselves
and
if i didn't really like myself i
wouldn't be on social media i'd be like
private account none of your business
stay away
i don't want you to find out that i'm
you know
not that smart not that funny uh uh you
know whatever it is they're trying to
hide and it's subconscious which is the
crazy part because i talk to a lot of
people
and they've got and they've got private
accounts or whatever i'm talking to them
and i'm like
you know why is it you won't just come
off that and some of it sounds arrogant
like you know it doesn't matter you know
so-and-so doesn't have social media they
use one famous person that's that's
successful and they don't have social
media
or someone runs their social media well
at the end of the day it is your calling
card and if you plan on being in
business you better have social media
and you better know how to run it or
hire someone who does because it matters
you know i started trying to do tick
tock myself
for about a month and about a month and
a half you know i couldn't get any views
any traction no one was following me no
one gave a rat's ass about it
and then and then i knew this guy that's
funny and i said listen why don't you
give me a little help on my tick tock
you can just manage it and make sure you
post three to five times a day because
it's a you gotta keep posting on that
and now i'm over 200 000 followers in
less than two months so it's so it's
like you have to know what you're doing
or hire someone who does and then be
yourself be authentic and don't be
afraid to put yourself out there and if
you have to go
figure out how to like yourself first
well then you know put that on the
checklist
do you think some people avoid social
media because they're more introverted
and they're just anxious
maybe on the surface i think i think
they avoid social media because they
don't want to they do not want people
see who they are
like it's none of their business
well why are you so worried about what
people might think because that's what
it boils down to michaela people are
worried about what other people think
way too much
if everyone could literally
pretend that there was no one else on
the planet you would see people act
completely differently
do you think it'd be a positive change
for the individual yes and for the most
part yes because i think generally
people are good i don't think
everybody's mean and evil but i i also
think that you would see some fake ass
you know people
for who they are if if if they didn't
think anyone was watching you wouldn't
see a lot of these gurus and social
medias you know because i work with a
lot of these subject matter experts and
um i see that what they're teaching and
preaching and then i also see them in
their real life and a lot of times they
don't match
they're they're saying to do this but
they don't do that
you know i think authenticity
uh is is vitally important nowadays
i think you need to be real i think you
need to say what you say
like if you follow me at all michaela
you you hear me say [ __ ] where people
are like
i can't believe he said that
well
what's so bad about it first of all and
that's my opinion and i think if more
people
started to learn who they are and
started to like themselves what they're
going to find is the people that uh
should be around them are going to come
around because it resonates with those
people as well and the people that are
offended by it will will fade
and if you just let that natural
filtering process happen you're going to
be in a much better environment because
the people around you like you for you
versus me pretending to be something
acting like something that i'm not and
then i'm surrounded by a bunch of people
that that you know i'm walking on
eggshells and or it doesn't last very
long because i slip up and the real me
says something or does something or
or or you know politically or otherwise
and now all of a sudden i'm i'm in a
freaking world of drama
for no reason do you think yeah yeah do
you think that some of these like
so-called gurus i like how you say gurus
by the way gurus
but do you think some of these so-called
gurus are
saying the things they're saying
because they're trying to fix those
exact problems within themselves have
you seen that
most of them
are trying to sell something
really that's so unfortunate
yeah
agreed
you know yeah
there's there's some good ones there's
some good ones out there there's some
people with real experience out there
but for the most part
especially on social media
you have to be careful of who you're
listening to most people are just
regurgitating [ __ ] somebody else said
they don't have their own opinion but
when someone has their own opinion and
voices their own opinion with conviction
and certainty
that's when they start to gain
popularity
that's when people actually start to
follow them now the hate comes their way
as well but you can't look at the hate
too many people
are so afraid of the hate
they'll never find the love
and isn't that what it's really all
about love
almost sounds guruy
yeah now who's the guru for for people
who are trying to figure out how to like
themselves do you have tips on how to
start acting so that you like yourself
yeah i think i think the first thing you
have to do is kind of forgive yourself
for the past because most people dwell
so much on what happened and what the
past was is they can't focus on the
present or the future so so they're just
stuck in the past so you just need to
forgive yourself that's step one step
two you need to commit
to do what you say you're gonna do you
have to literally
manufacture if if that's a
for lack of a better word
integrity
and ethics and it doesn't matter again
that's why you got to forgive yourself
first it doesn't matter you used to lie
cheat steal screw people over like
everyone deserves a second chance just
forgive yourself apologize to yourself
just like you would in a relationship if
you and i were in a fight and i wanted
to repair the relationship the first
thing i'm going to do is apologize
michaela i'm sorry i didn't you know but
i'm not going to continue to to act the
way i did and then apologize every time
that's so you forgive yourself and then
the next step is you have to commit to
do what you say you're going to do
i think we chip away at our self-esteem
and our self-worth because we don't do
what we say we're going to do and deep
down we know that
so to step two would be commit to do
what you say you're gonna do and then
step three is gonna be rack up the wins
we're taught to set these massive goals
and then we fall short of those goals
and that chips away at our self-esteem
now we can be
persuaded that it's good oh your goal
was this and you almost made it that's
pretty good no it isn't it's a loss and
your mind knows the difference between a
win and a loss it doesn't necessarily
know the difference between a big win
and a little win but it knows the
difference between a w and an l
so you rack up the wins by setting small
goals on a regular basis it's just small
attainable goals you commit to do what
you say you're going to do set small
goals so you start winning and so pretty
soon i think subconsciously you
feel like you're a winner and you start
to sit a little
straighter and walk a little taller and
the next thing you know you start to
look around and feel like you deserve a
little bit more and you do and here's
the crazy part when you start to
actually feel like you deserve a little
bit more you start to act as if you
deserve a little bit more and then step
four comes into play that's when people
will start talking [ __ ] the haters will
come out even your friends and family
who are you to think who are you to act
this way who who do you think you are
well this is step four you have to get
rid of the
the hate and the headlines like
get rid of all negativity including your
own and get rid of it and then step five
is you need to figure out what success
looks like because too many people
they don't even know what success looks
like and if i told you go find somebody
in a room full of thousand people
you'd ask me well what do they look like
but when we're out there hunting for
success
we don't even know what success looks
like we've never taken the time to to
really determine what that is for
ourselves
and you're not going to find it if
unless you don't unless you know what it
looks like
and you can't visualize and i think
visualization
is
been proven scientifically through many
studies where it actually works so step
five would be to visualize you know who
you are where you are who you're with
what is what it feels like get that
emotion and then step six is to seek new
knowledge every day
a lot of people don't read michaela a
lot of people don't look for new
information and if you really break it
down to common sense
if you want something else
in your life because you're not happy
with where you are or who you are if you
want something
else you you kind of have to do
something different and in order to do
something different you have to change
your beliefs because i believe
the reason you do what you do is because
you believe what you believe for
whatever reason you were taught that
whatever reason you believe what you
believe so you that's what drives what
you do and how you act and how you
choose
so in order to change your belief
you have to get new information because
the only way to change what you believe
is to get new keyword new information if
you if you never get new information
you're going to continue to believe what
you believe makes sense the only way to
change a belief is to get new
information like oh i didn't think that
was hot and then i touched it that's new
information so every single day i would
i would recommend people seek new
information pick up a book you know
listen to a podcast and seek new
information i think those six steps
will eventually over time 120 days 180
days start to start to
build your self-esteem and your
self-worth and that'll begin that
journey and then you just continue like
like it's not something you did it's
something you do
you become a better person become a
better version of yourself
every day you outdo yourself don't worry
about others worry about you
that'd be my tip
that was a very that was six very solid
tips
i'm impressed that was good
well that's what i did that's what i did
you know i used to be a little more
insecure and by the way
insecure when people say insecure they
think you know oh poor intimidated no
sometimes insecure comes out as arrogant
[ __ ] selfish
uh uh you know because they're trying to
protect this little you know scared
[ __ ] so at the end of the day you know
i used to kind of be that way where i'd
put people down and make fun of people
all the time because i technically
didn't really believe in myself so those
are the six steps that i developed
over a two or three year period where i
started to walk a little taller and i'd
get beat up you know people would start
talking [ __ ] and i'd start listening to
the [ __ ] well that's
that's step four you gotta stop that and
pretty soon
over time man you're gonna actually go
dude you know what i've got ethics i'm a
good person i actually try to help
people you start to learn who you are
what you want and literally you start to
be able to
you know own that and once you know
yourself
you become you get this power i think
that is hard to teach or hard to acquire
i think the only way you can acquire it
is to get to know yourself 100
authentically know yourself
i completely agree okay
what what does your version of success
look like you mentioned people have a
vague idea of what success looks like so
what do you think it looks like for you
anyway
i you know freedom you know the ability
to go where i want with whom i want
however i want and the ability to give
in abundance
and not uh sacrifice
myself in other words
okay i like nice [ __ ]
i don't wanna i don't wanna give so much
that i don't have anything i don't wanna
be gandhi okay
i wanna have enough to where i have
anything i want go where i want with
whom i want and
give
an abundance that's my idea of success
so like right now if i if you had a
cause you were raising money for a
special cause i'd say uh oh michaela
here i'll donate five million and you're
like no [ __ ] oh absolutely like i think
that's my idea of success obviously i
need a cause
what am i doing
you have a cause don't you i know you
already you already offered you already
offered me your uh lightspeed vt which
we should talk a bit about because you
said you've developed this light speed
vt 20 years ago when the internet
started which is super early to get into
any type of
internet business so can you
explain what lightspeed vt is a bit
it's a web-based software that allows
you to create interactive content or
just any kind of content but interactive
if you're really trying to allow people
to learn better but
it's a it's a web-based software that
allows you to create deliver track and
measure
content
so if i needed to teach you how to
answer my phones or or i need to teach
you how to you know do jiu jitsu
you're
in order to learn
i found that there's four key
ingredients to to effectively teach
somebody it's good content you have to
have good content in the first place if
you teach someone to do it wrong
they'll do it wrong so you have to have
the right way to do it in the first
place good content second is repetition
most companies miss repetition most
individuals miss repetition so you need
repetition look at school they teach you
teach you teach you test you teach you
teach you your abcs how many times were
you told to say that so you need good
content repetition practice which most
people miss
and then you need accountability which a
lot of people miss so with those four
things good content repetition practice
and accountability only then can you
effectively train somebody
and
92 percent of companies that have a
training program at all because you'd be
amazed how many companies they don't
even offer training but
the ones that do
fail to deliver all four of those a lot
of them are delivering good content
but there's no repetition no practice no
accountability so they fail to actually
deliver the punch uh sometimes you know
there's good content and repetition but
there's no practice and there's no
accountability so you need all four of
those things well when i realized this
20 years ago i was out on the road doing
it manually and that's not scalable and
i knew i would be limited so i thought
what can i do
to
deliver those four things and the
internet was just coming out and i'm
like you know obviously i need to be on
the internet and and that internet
allows me to track measure and monitor
so i just
have
my team develop interactive technology
where someone could take a video and ask
questions just like i would in real life
and based on those questions
i could respond appropriately so whether
it be you know teaching you something or
selling you something see so like i
could give you a free course
ask some questions find out oh she's
interested completely in something i
totally didn't even realize through this
interactivity and now i can come over
here and present to you something that
really resonates or or you need
where a normal video a linear video
it asks no questions it just is what it
is so
i think we'll start seeing a lot more of
it in the future but that's what
lightspeed is it's just a web-based
system that allows you to
to create deliver track and measure
content
and when you do it correctly in an
engaging way
you can either sell it
and and monetize your knowledge which
again i've helped a lot of people make
millions per month and i get a little
peace
um so that's how i make my millions
um or i can show companies how to
leverage the technology to develop a
training program where you know
their their turnover slows down their
liability reduces and they actually
train people better
and with you i said i'll let you use it
to teach people your your diet and your
beliefs because again there's a lot of
people out there michaela that are that
are facing
health issues
and and they don't know how to fix them
and guess what everybody's telling them
oh that meat diet's a bunch of [ __ ]
you're going to end up dead well how
come michaela's not dead
how come michaela had all these issues
and all she did was this so how do
people get to you well they're not going
to they can follow your podcast what if
there was a what if there was an
interactive version of you to work with
someone for 90 days to basically
educate them and teach them everything
that you've had to learn the hard way
yeah no that sounds that sounds really
useful how do you incorporate
accountability i know you are i have to
get out of moscow first
accountability by by by real time
tracking you know
testing mechanisms exercises that have
accountability mechanisms like for
example let's say you know day one i
tell you okay go to the gym and and do
30 push-ups and then the next day you
log in i pop up and i say okay did you
do your push-ups now if you hit yes if
you hit yes
technically that's accountability i'm
not necessarily following you to the gym
however
i could plug into your iphone and your
and your apple watch and see if your
heart rate went up you know nowadays
listen
i can do a lot of things to for
accountability but at the end of the day
it depends on who you're teaching and
what it's for but you know i can take
your picture every five seconds you know
start with the training session
i can ask you for passwords and key
codes and and you know secret questions
there's all kinds of ways to do it just
depends on what you're trying to train
them on
this episode is brought to you by hover
a domain name vendor that is absolutely
awesome for sponsoring me so if you need
a website show them some love so they
keep sponsoring me something that makes
hover special is they have a ton of
options for different endings on domains
it has over 300 domain name extensions
to choose from when building your brand
online you can end your website in blog
or dot diet or whatever instead of the
usual dot com if you so choose
i use hover for that reason
adding a dot something to your website
can be a better idea than a full on new
dot com i personally own at least eight
domains probably more i've bought every
iteration of michaela peterson that you
guys can spell wrong it's not your fault
my dad named me after mikhail gorbachev
and literally nobody knows how to spell
that
i swear i cannot recommend buying
domains from hover enough you'll always
find excellent technical support
available to answer any questions you
have their support team doesn't upsell
you they have free whois privacy
protection a clean user experience and
monthly sales on popular top level
domains check them out at hover.com mp
and get a 10
discount on all new purchases
having a website is very important for
anyone with a business hover.com mp
codemp enjoy the rest of the episode
okay let's let's i want some
entrepreneur questions then
um what what kind of advice
two questions two advice questions what
kind of advice do you have for
people in their twenties that are
entrepreneurial
what kind of advice
yeah well number one get started quit
worrying about failing everybody you
know is this
is afraid to fail when failure is
actually what you're looking for you
know believe it or not
so
getting started would be the the most
pressing thing
you know too many people want to
wait and study and
go to this class and that class when in
reality man just jump in what's the
worst that can happen failure
that's it
you know when i when i started
lightspeed everyone said it wouldn't
work and by the way i was way too early
it i went about eight years before time
caught up and so if i didn't have
tenacity and and
stick with it i probably i probably
never would have you know but
getting started is the most important
thing see here's the thing michaela
you have to take a chance
or work for someone who did there's so
many people that are that are afraid to
take a chance they just you know what if
this happens and what if that happens
and it goes back to what other people
think
see they're worried about what their
moms told them and their dad told them
you know they're worried about if what
if they're what if their friends laugh
at them what if they fail and fall on
their face what if their brother was
correct they're worried about everybody
else
i'd say number one you got to take a
chance
and then number two advice get really
good at solving problems quit running
from problems and start looking for
problems the the better you get at
solving problems i think
the more successful you're going to be i
always tell people you want a million
dollars solve a million problems
most people they avoid problems they
wake up every day literally avoiding
problems when when in reality you want
to you want to
find problems and get really good at
solving them
and then you need to make adjustments
like too many people out there you know
they get laser focused we're told you
know
never give up get laser focused no you
should give up on a lot of [ __ ]
you know
when i started lightspeed i i started
out to be the trainer i wanted to be the
guy the tony robbins the big name guy
i had my own content you know which
who's really original anymore anyway so
i had to learn it from somewhere but i
had my own version of content and i
wanted to be the big name i went out
there started running into competition
and bigger marketing budgets and so i
just decided to close the
people that already had the market share
on my software so i partnered and
collaborated with my competition
now that's an adjustment so i would also
i would also tell them to make
adjustments man don't don't worry about
veering left and veering right i'm
literally the ceo of a software
company
and i started out to be a trainer that
is a completely different end result
and the only reason you know my
company's doing eight figures almost
nine figures
is because i was willing to make
adjustments so
i just keep giving tip after tip because
there's there's not one answer but for
20 years old i would say get started
quit being a puss quit worrying about
you know what might happen what might
not happen go out and make [ __ ] happen
sound advice it's also the fastest way
to learn you can learn from a book but
if you actually go and try and do it
that's the way faster way to learn
that's how kids learn right
realistically
yeah and you don't see a kid like fall
down a couple times when they're trying
to walk and be like well that didn't
work
stop walking
they just keep going
you'll get there
that's totally fair
okay okay so same question then so
that's 20 year olds if you could go back
and talk to
brad at 30 what kind of advice could you
give him
well that was only yesterday
now at 30 i would say you know
that's right when i started
actually becoming a decent human being
um
i would say good job you made the right
decision at 30 years old i helped
somebody make money i watched his whole
life change all i did was teach him how
to sell he went from making minimum wage
about 15 grand a month his whole life
got better his family's life got better
i saw him cheer up you know
they just become better human beings and
all i did was teach them how to make
money
at at that point in my life i literally
said i want to do this for more people
and i literally didn't realize it at the
time but that's when i shifted from
focusing on myself
to focusing on helping other people
so at 30 years old what's funny that you
picked that is because that's when i did
it i would say
good job you made the right choice
i've been i've been talking to a number
of
i seem to mostly talk to men on my
podcast for whatever reason i'm having
not all men but a lot of men and there's
seems to be something around the age of
30 that
a lot of men maybe people experience
that transforms them from focusing on
kind of themselves
and focusing outward or identifying
where their flaws are and starting to
work on them i don't know what it is
about 30 but it seems to be a special
age
maybe some sort of maturity women are
more mature
i think men at 30 is like you know when
a when a
woman hits 20.
you know
oh my god that's a horrifying thought i
was going to say 25 you think it's 20
jesus
i i know women are more mature a little
bit smarter
a little bit faster yeah yeah like like
this whole and it's funny too because
your dad's
i i think
you know fame came from that whole he
she thing and and that gender thing
i think women have the advantage in the
world
i don't know why everyone you know wants
to [ __ ] about that whole thing because
like to me
a woman
has the advantage i think over men they
may not know it but they do
anyway that's another subject
for develop developing faster
definitely for developing
faster if i mean
i'm not allowed to say this but like if
i had my you can say it on my podcast
this is a safe space if i had my
preference you know between a male and a
female uh
employee or or anything i would take for
business i would take women
really
well yeah i mean they're they're
yes they have the advantage like
you know now if i was going to war
you know with the weaponry of today
you know
men or women i suppose could do it but i
take men why well because we're going to
war
you know but for but for business and
persuasion and sales and and
and whatnot i'd take i'd take a female
in a heartbeat
that's interesting okay i want to delve
into that a little bit because i i mean
i don't have as much much experience
with you but i
i've worked with a lot of people
and i
i've worked with women and men and i
definitely prefer working with men
and
i've thought that the reason for that is
because
if i get
stressed out about something or get
critical of their work
generally speaking they don't get
offended and i found that if i work with
women and i get critical of work then
they get more offended
but i'm not doing like i guess i'm not
doing sales so maybe it's different for
sales
i believe and i was referring to more
like when i say business it basically
boils down to sales so yes sales
interesting because because i think i
think a great sales person has empathy i
think women are more empathetic
um i think i think a lot of times you
know they they they
you know smell better look better
um
which is which is again it's an
advantage you know uh people that can be
leveraged so
you know at the end of the day i've got
a lot of you know male counterparts that
are fantastic but
but i think women have a slight
advantage in in the world of business
maybe maybe not again for pay gap and
you know
all of the nonsense that that i hear
about
maybe that's true and i think it is true
basically uh but at the end of the day
when it comes to sales and persuasion i
think women have the advantage
they don't use it but they have it yeah
okay maybe
yeah
i can see that i had somebody on the
podcast a few months ago who said that
and hopefully i get this right but some
type of asian woman is now out earning
white males in the states
well maybe that's the political pressure
this maybe that's the political pressure
that's been put on employers to pay
women more
i don't know if it's that or
just some of the cultures that
asian people are brought up and is more
focused on
do your work
you know study for six hours a day go to
university become a doctor or a business
person don't go into humanities or
you'll be an embarrassment and then they
just end up earning more because they're
in
businesses that actually make money
rather than
trying to be i don't know a writer not
that you know i'm not trying to be a
writer but
or yeah maybe they're smarter
personally though like like honestly
when it boils down to it like does
someone really care like if i'm paying
let's say
a hundred grand for this position i
don't care if it's a male or a female
right i prefer i'd prefer a female in in
a
business setting but
i don't care which one it is if it's
worth a hundred grand to a man it's
worth a hundred grand to a woman
i don't look at oh it's worth 80 if it's
a girl
it's worth 120 if it's a guy like who
thinks like that
i don't know i think it might accident
it it also might accidentally happen at
least i've learned this from my dad too
because women are in general more
agreeable which might be why they could
be more persuasive at sales too because
they're understanding and like you said
compassionate because they're more
agreeable they're less likely to bargain
up front for a raise or more money
they'll just be like yeah okay i'll take
it so that it's not capabilities it's
just they won't
go there because they're more agreeable
or
more neurotic too so more s
easily stressed on average not every
woman is like that obviously but i could
be part of it
i think any good businessman though yeah
isn't going to care they just want to
look at output right
is the person i'm hiring useful or not
and
bottom line
yeah
so you said when you started lightspeed
vt you had eight years where you were
kind of too early for the market which
makes sense because people weren't
really doing online courses until fairly
recently so how did you manage to keep
that business
running for eight years
sales and persuasion
i literally convinced people to do it
i sold people
otherwise i wouldn't be in business
um but you know like
my car was up for repossession multiple
times because i only had so much money
and i had to determine where to put it
you know do i pay rent do i bank my car
payment or do i you know
buy the gas it requires to go knock on
doors
you know so so
at the end of the day a lot of people
are not willing to sacrifice their
credit and and
when you're not willing to sacrifice for
what you want what you want becomes the
sacrifice and i just wasn't i i just
i wasn't willing to sacrifice like i was
going to make it
no matter what i knew i knew online
training was better way of doing it
you know people can say that you know oh
it's better in person and they used to
but it's not better in person
you can't
you can't do
in person what you can do online
you leverage technology
or you die
period so so i knew 20 years ago
that it was going to be better more
effective less expensive more scalable
and no one could talk me out of it and
they tried and people said you're crazy
you know we do it belly to belly this is
never going to work i i tried to get 50
000 for half of my company once the guy
said no i still know that guy
um you know i i i literally was told
this is not going to happen but i just
knew that it would and so for eight
years i you know when it pushed came to
shove i made a deal i closed the deal i
did whatever i needed to do to to get
whatever
resources i need i was resourceful
but
in reality
i wasn't that smart i didn't realize it
was going to take eight years i would
have told you if you knew me then
i would have told you michaela in 90
days i'm gonna be a millionaire
and and i believed it and so 90 days
later you would have showed up said well
what how's it going brad i would have
said oh my god dude 90 more days
it's it's blowing up it's like i've got
so many deals in the in the pipeline 90
more days i'll be a millionaire and i
literally said 90 more days
for eight years
and i believed it that's the key like i
wasn't smart enough to realize bro it's
not going to be 90 days it's going to be
eight more years had i been smart enough
or aware enough to realize it's gonna be
eight years of struggle i probably would
have gave up just like it most people
would have
it wasn't like i'm some hero where i'm
like you know i'm not giving up
consistency like i didn't know then
what i
realized now i was naive i really
believed in 90 days the world would
change and [ __ ] anyone can do anything
for 90 days right i've been drunk longer
than that
i i think
i mean you might call it naive and
perhaps it's a bit naive but i've
definitely gotten myself through some
pretty shitty situations
by saying
three more months this will be over and
then when that comes around saying
exactly the same thing and full-on
believing it i can do this for three
more months can i do it for three more
yeah i can do it for three more but like
sometimes like you said if you you think
whatever journey i'm on is gonna take
two years and it's gonna suck the whole
time i don't know if it sucked for you
but there are journeys that suck the
whole time
that can be totally overwhelming just
leave you in bed so doing small you know
one day at a time 90 days at a time it
might be naive but it definitely works
for
journeys painful processes
absolutely i think i think that was the
key right there is the 90 days i was
going to write a book called how do you
get anything you want in 90 days and
then spell the days d-a-z-e because you
almost have to get in this
this days where like you know three more
months i can do that
and if you just take those little 90
days look up
if you're not where you want to be look
back down act like 90 days you'll be
there and just keep doing that process
just
little steps at a time
you'll make it i think anyone has the
ability to to
to make it as an entrepreneur and really
if you look up the word entrepreneur it
just means someone who's taking
larger than normal risk
and you know you take a risk every time
you leave your house technically
so what's the big financial part why are
why is so many people afraid of
risking financially
money is a tool
that's another entrepreneurial blunder
i've seen people make and i didn't make
it fortunately because i was a little
bit frivolous
with my with my loot
um
but what happens is people will start a
business and they and they start to
succeed a little bit so they start to
get a little money and then they hold on
to that money because they they remember
what it was like being broke
well when you hold on to your money
that's your those are your tools
that's your tool and when you hold on to
your tool
and then wonder how do i how do i grow
how do i expand and you're and you're
not willing to let go of the number one
tool you have
which is money
and that's a mistake people make
you want to continue to use that money
and continue to be willing to lose it
all like right now i take very large
financial risks not stupid risks
calculated risks but
i'm not afraid to lose it all why
because i was broke when i started like
what's the worst that could happen i'm
broke again it's not that bad being
broke i was happy broke i'm happy rich
but
being broke is hard and making money is
hard so pick one like it's just as hard
being broke michaela
like i don't know what your life was
like growing up i i can't imagine your
family having much money they don't pay
professor [ __ ]
no my mom was a stay-at-home mom
yeah so you probably grew up normal
right
not not a lot of money and and whatnot
but but at the end of the day
what gives people opportunity attention
notoriety attention just go get
attention
figure out something that we where you
where you get attention because money
and opportunity
follow attention get some attention what
before your dad like blew up
uh uh
what what was he like just you know
go to work a day guy right
well
not really he was kind of exactly the
same he still worked all the time like
if he he still worked all the time
he hasn't actually changed very much
he's making more money now
there's more stress well but that's my
point
the attention
brought the opportunity
no
oh yeah 100
so again when you look at him or you
look at you or you look at me like
the more known i get the more
opportunities i get i get i had an
opportunity the other day somebody with
a 20 year old insurance company
multi-million dollar insurance company
said brad i've been following you for
five years i love who you are i love
what you say i'd like to go into
business with you i'm like what do you
mean
he says well he tells me a story he's
got a financial organization you know
it's doing millions of dollars a year
and it really boils down to recruiting
and training
and i said okay and he says so i want to
i want to start a company with you
you know
and and literally replicate
my 20-year business we'll give you the
you know access to the top contracts the
top software the top processes
everything at the very very top over
20-year period and we basically just
white label it and and
start a new one
i never would have gotten that
opportunity if nobody knew who i was
and i said why me he said i just love
your attitude i love your authenticity
but more importantly because i think you
could drive a lot of people to our
business with your social media
i'm like cool and again that's only
because i get attention and i and i only
get a little tiny baby bit of attention
like nobody knows who i am but but
enough people know who i am that i can
see holy [ __ ] the more i'm known
liked or not the more i'm known the more
opportunity and money comes my way and
at the end of the day that's the bottom
line
so if you're gonna start a business you
know figure out how to get attention and
and and don't fly under the radar and
don't keep your mouth shut
get attention like get as much attention
as you can and and focus on it people
say to me a lot to college people
you know college age they they say brad
what would you do if you could start
over at 20.
i said i would master marketing
yeah
when you can drive leads and get
attention which is marketing to me drive
leads and interest that's attention
if you master marketing you're
guaranteed to make seven figures plus ev
like people big companies will pay you
seven figures to drive leads their way
but when you have the ability to grab
attention get leads get interest
digitally especially
you've got that ability that skill
you can drive it towards selling
freaking coffee mugs with a with a word
on it and end up becoming the
number one coffee mug
dealer in the world
get attention
get attention
yeah wow that was you're full of tips
okay uh last question i have for you
then
if you're somebody who gets a whole
bunch of opportunity
how do you decide which ones to take and
which ones to say no to
that's a great question you know and i
think you develop that over time and and
you do your best but i think
it's intuition
i think i think you ask some questions
and you make a decision and you trust
your gut
and you trust your intuition and uh
that's i mean that's really
the bottom line at least for me i mean
there may be some scientific intelligent
way of saying that but
you know i listen to opportunities and i
make a decision and usually i've made
good ones and sometimes i've made bad
ones
there was a guy that came to me one time
all he wanted to use is one of my
offices young kid
now see again you tell me but
his product was called bum fights
where literally he would go film
bums
homeless
fighting and doing stupid [ __ ]
now now
i thought to myself you know because
everybody likes to see fights well he's
out there filming bums
fighting and he called it bum fights and
i'm like dude that's pretty good what's
your marketing plan he said i'm gonna
send a tape to howard stern
and i said cool but what's your
marketing plan and he said that's that's
what i'm going to do
and i said well that's stupid as hell
i knew it would be interesting and i
knew people would like watching fights
but i thought it was stupid and all he
wanted to give me 10
of his company just to let him use an
office which was empty and i said no
and bum fights went on to become
really popular and really famous
but then michaela
he
they got arrested because they were
giving them
alcohol and drugs and money and money to
to fight and do dumb [ __ ] and apparently
that's against the law so
so they got they got they got in trouble
now i don't know if i would have let
them use my office and i would have
owned 10 that i would have been looped
into that [ __ ] but but maybe because i
wasn't involved at all
but but but then again i think to myself
financially that was a bad decision it
went big that you know the guy got 20 30
40 million dollars bought out from this
other company wow buy the property
rights and and that would have been 10
percent mind for letting them use my
office i said no but then later they got
in a lot of legal trouble so did i make
a good decision or a bad decision
i feel like that's a reasonable decision
i can see where you're coming from
though did howard stern pick it up
they they sent a tape to howard stern he
picked it up and it went freaking hog
wild it's unbelievable that that
actually worked that was his marketing
plan
that was the main reason i said no like
what a stupid marketing plan you're
gonna send a tape to howard stern what
if he doesn't watch it like that's your
only plan he said yeah that's all
they're gonna do and i it made me pass
but when you look back it's like was it
a good decision or a bad decision i
don't know i don't know what would have
happened i don't have a crystal ball so
guess what my advice if you guys are
looking at decisions you know just trust
your instinct i think
deep down we all have a compass inside
of us that guides us and
not many people listen to it
so listen to opportunities ask
intelligent questions and then just
quiet quiet the mind and all the people
and just what how do you feel about it
if you feel good about it go worst thing
you made a mistake big deal
i bet the intuition is the number one
um
let's say picker you have at your
disposal like if you want to make a
decision listen to your listen to your
gut listen to your instincts
it's usually right
yeah i think a lot like i was
like your instincts tell you that you
need to get a virtual training system
oh you're not you're not listening
you're not listening to your instincts
michaela
no they're telling me that i just have
to get my dad's business in order and
then
and then your dad needs a virtual
training system by the way if if you
guys want to make
more millions
than anybody i've ever helped and i've
helped tony robbins grant cardone damon
john your dad because he's a real
educator
like he's not he's not a fake guru like
people need to know his [ __ ]
if he had the system
there would be businesses and
individuals and universities and and all
these different people and i could help
you
so easily
you'd make zillions of dollars with his
as well so again you want to get his
business in order get him a vt system
all i want is just a little piece for my
niece a little fraction of the action
i'll do the rest
but hey whenever you're ready i'm
whenever you're ready i'm here i'm gonna
be ready for stands i i most certainly
am i just need to get some things
organized i'm never gonna say
before we can
take on projects i like the idea
obviously i've been on your podcast
we've talked i do like the idea i think
is really smart
well everybody okay thank you so thanks
for being on my podcast
thank you for having me on thank you for
coming online where can people find you
if they want to find you on social media
where should they go
uh you know
my favorite platform is instagram so on
instagram if you're dming me it's me and
i'm talking um the other ones i post
there but you know i don't really
comment i don't really pay attention to
the comments so i would say instagram if
you really want to get a hold of me
other than that just you know
bradley.com and it's ellie ah
most people say is that leah i say only
if you drink tia
but
don't think it's l-e-e-l-e-a bradley.com
that'll tell you what i'm up to and how
to find me everywhere or just google me
okay thank you very much for coming on
that was fun that was very informative
my pleasure my pleasure
[Music]
you